I have a challenge for you today I
challenge anyone to tell me what
substance Jared Kushner communicated in
the 60-second video that I'm about to
show you I already mentioned earlier
that Donald Trump's slumlord son-in-law
Jared Kushner son of convicted felon
Charles Kushner showed up at the White
House corona virus virus press briefing
last Thursday and his presence was not
only sinister it was also dystopian at
one point Jared Kushner went on this
rant about how the the the stockpile is
for us it's not for the states at
another point Jared Kushner spoke for 58
seconds in a screed laced with
meaningless management buzzwords that I
believe his record-setting I believe
that in the 60 seconds I'm going to play
for you Jared Kushner has set a record
for the most meaningless buzz words per
minute without communicating anything of
substance whatsoever so let's look at it
together and what I suggest you do is
really focus and make an effort not to
be lulled by the words that he's saying
and realized that he's speaking a lot
but he's saying zero he's not saying
anything here the question to Jared was
about you know data being used to make
decisions when do you send ventilators
and masks and supplies to States Jared
has famously said New York is asking for
more ventilators than they really need
states don't really need all the stuff
they're asking for and he's sort of
addressing here how decisions are being
made I contend Jared says nothing of
substance in his answer take a look here
what the president asked is that all of
the recommendations that we make be
based on data he wanted us to be very
rigorous to make sure that we were
studying the data collecting data a lot
of things in this country were happening
very quickly and we want to make sure
that we were trying to keep updating our
models and making sure that we were
making informed decisions and informed
recommendations to him based on the data
that we were able to collect and put
together the president wants to make
sure that we had the best people doing
the best jobs and make
sure that we had the right people focus
on all the things that needed to happen
to make sure that we can deliver in
these unusual times for the American
people
the president also instructed me to make
sure that I break down every barrier
needed to make sure that the teams can
succeed this is a an effort where the
government is doing things that the
government doesn't normally do where
we're stretching we're acting very
quickly and the president wants to make
sure that the White House is fully
behind the different people running the
different lines of effort to make sure
that we get everything done in a speed
that the president demands we collect
and look at data we update models we
make decisions and make recommendations
based on the data we get the best people
in the right jobs we have people focused
correctly we want to deliver teams must
succeed we are breaking down barriers
Donald Trump directed us to act quickly
on this Jared Kushner said nothing and
you know that Ivanka sitting at home
super impressed with this Wow look at
that great job that Jared's doing Mike
Pence was standing nearby looking
pleased with that dumb smirk on his face
because it sounded good like clearly
this guy is more articulate than Donald
Trump and people were probably refreshed
in a way that he wasn't struggling to
get through a sentence like Donald Trump
but he said nothing and this is called
management in some circles what Jared
Kushner said they're not doing anything
I'm not talking about doing anything
just saying stuff like that it's called
effective management in some circles and
so this is why we have a real problem so
my challenge remains tell me what data
and actions were actually communicated
there by Jared Kushner I'm hoping I'm
hoping that we don't see Jared back at
another one of these press conferences
ever again today's program is sponsored
in part by the galaxies series which is
a series of three books written by a
really great author I thought and I
would call the genre sort of political
science fiction I've really enjoyed the
books it looks at the future it explores
what could happen to Planet Earth if we
stay on our path environmentally it
deals with space travel it takes a sort
of deep dive into political psyche
and it's a really intriguing sort of
dystopian look at the future the stories
are told from a perspective that I think
people in the audience would really
appreciate and there's a ton of really
excellent artwork also that accompanies
the books I read a lot of books in this
genre and I'll tell you these books are
very well written the plot the
characters are compelling if you're
someone who likes politics and sci-fi
you'll really like these books again
it's the galaxy series check it out for
yourself you can find it at david
pakman.com slash galaxy